with more than 15 million players online
Call of Duty warzone made a huge impact
in its opening week so whether you're
brand new to the game or have played
since launch we've got you covered with
eight more tips that you might not know
we all know that the opening minutes of
any battle royale are stressful to speed
up the looting process set your looting
style to contextual press by going to
menu controller use and reload behavior
then switch it to contextual tap this
makes it so you can simply tap the
looting button rather than holding in
town be careful though this one changes
the way you reload as well with a map as
large as a bar dance long-range scopes
in your loadout are always a good idea
the only problem is the glint of your
lens can easily give away your position
in post launch updates even night vision
and thermal sights were giving glint to
get around this pick a merc thermal
optic losing your super long-range isn't
so bad with the added benefit of thermal
detection it's perfect for checking out
what lies ahead by now you've probably
been targeted for a bounty avoiding the
price on your head by evasion and
running up the clock can make you some
money but if you're brave enough so can
fighting back keep an eye out for the
threat indicator and you can plan an
ambush or a counter-attack with your
squad holding out in a taller building
can help weed out any enemy squads
nearby of course now write hunt for them
is always a welcomed option
to get to your LZ as quickly as you can
cut your parachute and tilt your player
down nose first to your desired location
as you near ground level quickly open
and cut your parachute again before
touching down you should also be
checking your surroundings by tapping
the shoulder button to fly with a
third-person view
keep in mind that the fall distance here
is a little more forgiving than you
think you can safely fall without a
parachute roughly two stories also for
your adrenaline junkies out there once
you've cut your parachute you're free to
equip your gun and fire at other flying
targets just don't get distracted and
fall to your death driving around in any
vehicle makes a ton of noise and even
makes you visible on the radar here's an
old battlefield trick you may remember
swapping your seat can help you dodge
oncoming fire switching seats with your
squad mate can easily throw up anyone
who's firing at you while it's not
always a sure thing it's an easy way to
save some precious HP before you run
their asses over and if you're in a
helicopter you can use this technique
for a better position to sharp shoot at
enemies below if you've made it to the
Gulag with a friend you can help each
other out in a few ways while the
pinging system is disabled players with
mics can eat each other using call-outs
during the 1 v1 battle
spray-painting your squad mate a bright
color can also distinguish who's who
down in the pit also while watching from
above you can set off explosives like c4
and claymores with rocks previously we
talked about how taking on contracts can
help your team make some fast cash but
if you want to make some serious dough
try taking them on back-to-back
contracts have a continual bonus the
more you complete the higher the bonus
completing 5 contracts can score you
tons of XP thousands in cash and a shot
at some legendary loot other ways to
earn some serious cash include wiping
out entire enemy squads avoiding those
bounties and of course looking out for
those orange supply crates now for some
door etiquette if you've been playing
warzone without having played modern
warfare know that you don't need to
always hold down the button to get
through a door simply sprinting into it
will get the job done but be careful
it's extremely loud
you can also quietly see what's on the
other side of the door by aiming down
your sights and slowly approaching it
for a useful peak option and just in
case you didn't know double tapping the
Run button lets you super sprint for a
second if you have some tips that didn't
make the list share them in the comments
below and if you're interested in more
war zone tips feel free to watch our
other video with nine essential tips on
how to help you win for continued
coverage of call of duty war zone keep
it here at GameSpot
[Music]
you